[Music]
three two one
hey what's up everybody welcome back to
off-the-record where we talk about
whatever the [ __ ] we want
mm-hmm and today is a very special
special day you'll notice that the
laptop is not with me it's with my guy
Nelson because we have special guest
show cat how is Japan Byron yeah you're
like more Japanese than I am now hey
just how does it feel living out your
salaryman life the life that I always
wanted translate for me so you're
closest to the mic he said what is it
like now that you're a salaryman this is
this is like talking to like one of
those news reporters the delay you
thought your Japanese is good
where's your hot spot by your Japanese
maybe that's closer okay the better it's
why because of that path but the hot
spot is pocket that's my hot spot first
of all haven't got laid yet
no one wants to talk to you you always
have to make the first step because
Japanese people are just never gonna
talk to you I like live my friend
she tried asking somebody in the grocery
store like hey how's the weather
I looked up I'm hella weird and just
like walk away she called you weird
Japanese - it's oh yeah II think you
just man and she's like [ __ ]
I said nice weather today in the
elevator if you talk to someone in the
elevator people look at you like you're
[ __ ] crazy
it's either yeah it's either like you
keep to yourself or if there's like a
special relationship between like you
and the customer like if it's
specifically you're in class and you get
to talk to somebody or you're at the
store you get to talk to somebody then
nobody talks randomly to another person
unless you're at like the club or
something
how's Japanese clubbing though Ryan
except people I I can't there's two we a
lot of weird things happen when you nuke
a country Oh God
I can say it though how's the Japanese
Cobbing live other Japanese clubbing
yeah they have really so I went to this
club in Osaka right because like that's
where like I'm at usually and you know
they playing like top 40 on some of the
floors and then I was looking at you
know like for why the floor to floor
floor and then I'm like floor floor it
says kpop and I'm like oh okay I'll
check it out and then they just play
cube like I belong yeah [ __ ] ditch
like grew up and I just stayed oh my god
everybody was doing the dances and [ __ ]
and I'm like alright I'm here now did
you make friends there yeah like every
nerdy person like stays like in their
house so I don't get to like make
friends with like a lot of decent people
cuz like they're like dude I saw I like
smash here Smash Brothers or just
smashing
[Applause]
talking to people no one wants to
[ __ ] talk so I did hear that uh Japan
is a cool place to visit but when you
live there it's really lonely really
lonely with you guys are cooped up in
here for like 10 [ __ ] hours like yeah
10 hour I've only been here for like
three months but I can understand if you
get lonely it's because like people are
just little [ __ ] about it you know
everybody here like complains about how
lonely it is and stuff but that's if
like you know you don't do anything
about it like you can make friends it
just takes a little bit more effort and
it takes like you know like in America
right but then if you like you keep up
with like your studies and you keep up
with like make new friends okay look
this is why cuz Japanese people I
learned they only want to hang out like
once a week and then if you ask them to
hang out more than like twice in a week
they call you like oh you got too much
free time so Japanese holy [ __ ]
just like your life isn't work you must
be lazy is like you're free like you had
a lot of free time and Gina's like new
ones in like the person well they just
told me he was like what the [ __ ] wait
so basically America so you're basically
American yeah and one of the American
were American stereotypes or what what
Japanese what did you have these people
think of American pave so I've been told
this joke many times what do you call
someone who knows more than two
languages anyone that I learn American
exactly exactly and they're like what do
you call a person that knows one
language
that's pretty good goddamn right only no
one I know the best language is mobile
goddamn what else Americans [ __ ]
crazy ass Americans here dude like you
know like okay there's two types of
people that visit like a country right
there's one person that goes and like
you know kind of research is what
they're getting into like the cultures
law how to behave in public meditations
and then there's a second person who can
think they could just like treat like
any other country like America yeah yeah
yeah many times are they your friends or
your like your friends the ones are you
just meeting these people in Rande and
like passing no I mean well both
actually like why I kept one as a friend
because like my hello I feel like she's
saying she's so stupid you think you
could smash your huh you know hang out
with her you know II mean I'm like what
country is he from okay here's your
example right like you know like I know
both English and Japanese and the sound
like we would hang out with the mix of
Japanese friends and we would mix up
like American friends and then we were
trying to teach them slag right really
oh yeah like if you want to say this
food is good you say yeah that's a bomb
now you say is there like oh he made a
nuke joke that's all you made a bomb
joke dude is like always pop or you can
say it's atomic bomb
so they're a bunch of Patrick oh my god
I just ignored her and then she was like
laughing by herself
I'm like dude like I would laugh with
you right now well I'm probably gonna
get killed
barn what is your favorite thing about
Japan right now do it honestly like the
eye candy you buy a virus yarn about you
this is your ulti are you can you pick
up the dialect yet did you pick it up
yet can you tell the difference between
Osaka and a no more like yeah yeah yeah
it's hella cute dude it's cute I love it
you can tell the drinks a little yeah
yeah like a little bit but I mean like
it's just it's just the bending of what
of how you say the word yeah so for
instance like you know thank you our ego
thinks it's like arigato you know it's
that's how you say in Tokyo
oh yeah thought if you learn Somali I
thought and Osaka it's already got Kol
oh I'm Shane cuz there's more Chinese
people there no it's more cuz there's a
lot of Chinese there a basket on it got
to know Cathy's is very hard it is it's
like I realized that I've been kicking
up a lot of it cuz I used to speak like
like this like very flat like what does
she want buying on this and then like
now it's like this cuz it goes bro it
goes from like it sounds like I'm
listening to something up Google
Translate just like arigato buy read
this over there and it's like when
you're at the train tracks and you hear
that voice talking about
exactly but now I'm hearing it like I
don't know like he's on a game show
Japanese game show gotta be crazy dude I
would watch 20th Paris else I feel like
your personality would have to be much
more toned down for the show and I'd be
like I feel like watching it and I could
I'd probably see you like trying to like
holding a joke I think Byron knows how
to be a Japanese enough he's much more
valid Japanese guy when Japanese mode
I'll watch it be like hey that's my
friend he's cool we're just supposed to
eat ramen sometime Wow he's the cooler
Japanese friend a new buyer just just
like just like you're not Filipino
anymore apparently Japanese I'm like no
and then people have been getting on the
dot that I'm Filipino what yeah you're
no one can ever figure out that you're
Filipino yeah like and on top of that
people have been direct at guessing that
I'm 26
oh that's weird right on the dot and it
happens very consistently Japanese
people spikes with everything I did
because they're judging you all the time
age he's out at this hour why he's 26 he
should be working no I was gonna say
like the reason why they're so on the
dot about is because they've been
watching your judging you silently for
this whole time so they're just like
aliens [ __ ] 26 year olds Filipino
trying to be Japanese guy like I didn't
get ID'd though oh yeah but it was
because I was wearing my [ __ ]
schoolgirl outfit okay well that might
skew things a lot
ready to show this plan I've been like
for a citation or like I went I went to
the you know convenience store on you
know 7-eleven
yeah gossipy 7-eleven and then I went up
there you know just had like two like
here in strong's yeah can't strong the
nine percent alcohol it's like the for
local of Japan but like it's much better
I love cute strong yes love that [ __ ]
man out of all the things in Japan I
missed that almost the most oh it's so
it's essential for Japan if you're if
you're of age anyway I went there and
then you know they asked me for like my
ID and then I was pretty drunk so I was
like how do I look you're like twenty my
ID and I kept looking at I just kept on
like mugging that no but I wore this
right and then I was going you know I
was going home on the train and I [ __ ]
send me a picture later and I can put it
up okay I'll send you it later I was
going to the bathroom right and then you
know I guys I got a piss in the urinal
so you know I just gotta you know like
take my skirt off get a little part in
my skirt skirt and just like pee right
doing that the [ __ ] janitor comes in
it
Oh
[Laughter]
that's supposed to make him more
comfortable
yeah I'm a - don't worry funny is like
you weren't even in a bathroom like did
you know that they banned alcohol in
yeah yeah cuz I heard it so it was so
crazy that they had to like yeah you
can't have like open containers but you
could like drink at these archives
around and then then you can like go
back out like in the street and stuff
right yeah I don't know if this is gonna
give any work for someone who has to
pull up media but there is a clip of
somebody like pushing over like a truck
yeah and you know I think it's mostly
like foreigners on deny America yeah so
say it's five Americans angry pooper
card [ __ ] stupid Oh anyway like let
me tell you about the girl I was talking
about you know like this girl who made
the atomic bombs everyone is different
one yeah so like we went to yeah we were
hanging out on Halloween and then she
what's it called she's like yeah I'm
just like this random bar you know like
she's like trust me it's like she's like
typical valley girl and every time I
make fun of her she gets hell offended
and this bar like drink and then I went
to the bar with her and then she looked
at the waitress stating the hi
and then she's like do you guys have
anything like strong hair like I'm
looking for something like on the rocks
like translators just like but everyone
here speaks English
you're in another country made friend
with friends with the worst America I
keep her around
oh she's open to learn you know know how
did she pass to go to Japan and teach
she's teaching English I'm assuming no
she's that too
she she has her own business right and
then she moved here by herself house way
off just because she was like tired of
her financial job in the stage she's
like yeah I'm like Yolo I'm just gonna
go to Japan yeah yeah okay okay dude no
but this oh my god this [ __ ] is crazy
I hope she doesn't watch this I don't
think she wants it dude
no you know what she's fun six to six
[ __ ] Jake he is did Oh perfect
Oh and that's where we had our video I
doesn't know are you kidding and then
what's it called
I was she's like yeah I didn't know that
futons come with like this big like
bamboo like pallet and I'm like what you
didn't look at that yeah I thought I
could just carry it home she was like
carrying it home and like and then like
she this random car passes by and then
you know in here's all you need help and
she's like yes please and she gets into
the car with the dude and then and like
he never saw her again
Oh like what's it like and she was
justifying it she's like yeah I could
take him okay but what have we had a gun
that's Japan and she literally like got
a ride from this random Japanese dude
and he like you know he's so dice just
dropped her off like near her house and
she carried the pallet all the way out
to your room and I'm just like I want to
blog your life
you gonna follow her around the camera
like how we want to follow pat around
with the camera that [ __ ] oh my god
closing remarks for the viewers here oh
wait yeah the camera yeah yeah we are
now happening it's right Byron we love
you we miss you I gather keeping it in I
will see you want a secondary do a
secondary message in case you don't keep
it in JK for life bye bye
nothing ok everybody go to Byron's
Instagram and tell them we love what we
love you I mean this is to come visit
I'll visit soon maybe next year
[Music]